[Music]
thank you very much for joining me laner
I have a couple of questions for you
regarding your chess upbringing I'm
curious to know um if you want to to
tell your fans a little bit about how
you got into chess
and um what made you stay yeah I learned
uh from my father when I was uh seven
between seven and 8 years old uh he
taught me the rules uh we didn't have a
chess board so he made with wood some
board and we got some chest pieces from
from a friend and so he was uh teaching
me a little bit but then at the same
time or less in my
hometown um the local Coach who is a
very good coach um went to my school and
he uh introduced chess to all the the
kids I was in third grade and so it was
I was learning at home and then the the
teacher came I mean the chess coach came
to to the school so I started going to
to the to the chess uh club and I
immediately fell in love with the game I
mean I would just uh from the start I
would I would try to get books and and
read the books when I was at home uh at
night and I was trying to get to to to
be at the club uh as much as I could
playing or or mostly playing but just uh
just uh trying to to be around um chess
and and then at some point I started
going to the to the chess club to the to
the coach's house because I'm from a
really small town so my my dad knew him
well and and then at some point it was
just like I was going to the chess club
but then in the evening my dad would
take me to his house and I would spend a
couple of more hours he had a huge
Library he's I think he still has it uh
all kinds of good books and I was just
immersed in this wall of Chess I think
it was really uh key for me because he
taught me not only the the game but also
to love the game like this great history
of great players and so on so I was
pretty I can say I was pretty serious
from from an early age like when I was
nine I I would really try to to study a
lot and then I started to have good
results in youth events when I was 9 or
10 and I I was national champion in Cuba
when I was uh 10
for kids under 12 and and with good
results you of course you get more more
motivation and and everything starts to
develop uh more easily so I that's how I
I started how do you feel that um people
these days are approaching classical
players I think they're having different
approaches for sure that's um my feeling
and it's it's it makes a lot of sense
because chess has changed obviously
very much with the with the new
technologies and and the the engines of
course um
primarily um so in general to me it's
it's it's an interesting question
whether we you should uh give the same
emphasis to starting the classics
nowadays for example as it was in my
time of course in my time uh there were
I mean that that was the main tool or
one of the main tools there were not
simply there were not other approaches
like uh computers and and and and so on
so um I think it has some value still
but um probably not the same the same
weight as it uh as it had 30 for years
ago thank you talking about classical
chess I know it's your favorite and last
year you finished third in the US
Championship um can you share a little
bit about the way one should prepare for
such an important competition yeah I
think uh as I said before I like the
classical format I think it's where you
um you ensure that the best players will
will come on top or at least they will
show their best chess I don't see I
don't see classical I I mean I don't see
how classical chess can be boring even
as a chess spectator I mean I I I I
think it's non-stop action especially in
a tournament like this where you have U
many games I mean it's you have six
games going on from the men's side and
then you have the women another six
games I don't think it's it's boring at
all from from uh
Spectators perspective and and and also
you get the something that you cannot
get with rapid and Blitz uh which is the
uh accuracy and correctness of play and
that's in to me that's where part of the
beauty of Chess lies where where you
find some almost m matical um Solutions
sometimes and great combinations deep
strategies uh that to me it's it's
mainly where the beauty of Chess resides
so I I don't I mean I think we we should
try to preserve it and I think it's a
it's a treasure I mean it's it's to me
that's real chess I mean um the other
formats are fun and are spectacular and
they have their their their uh good
things but I think if you're talking
about 100% chess like really true to the
spirit of Chess of the game it's it's a
classical but yeah I think in terms of
preparation um you you try to to get in
shape you try to uh take care of all the
details I mean as we all know uh it's
not only about the your chess form but
also about your general um uh shape in
life like let's say your mental state
your physical state and all those things
your diet your uh exercise so I mean I'm
I'm trying to get better at that I was
only I mean mostly I was focusing only
on on the chess part but I've been
trying to um to take care of all those
uh things as well especially when I'm uh
now I'm used to the fact that I'm almost
always the oldest participant in the US
Championship so uh it's it's really
important to to have a good routine and
and and good habits during the the
tournament so that you can perform well
so that's what I try thank you very much
Lanier those are great points and I hope
people who are watching are definitely
going to consider that as they continue
their path to become stronger players
and to you I wish you good luck in this
tournament and looking forward to seeing
you compete thank you very
[Music]
much